i'm ready for my next fun adventure in
that aspect
as far as reality tv i am open to the
idea
i have i don't know i think
i'm open to any possibility of being on
any show tasha adams
you are the new bachelorette what is
going on
but i was in the mix i guess multiple
sources confirmed to et
the 29 year old california native has
replaced claire crawley after
two weeks of filming on the bachelorette
what is happening what is happening i'm
not ready for this oh my god
e.t has learned that claire fell in love
with one of her contestants
which is why her time on the show came
to an end this is insane
claire left on good terms with the
producers but how exactly it will unfold
on tv
is still anyone's guess a source tells
e.t
tasha got a fresh start as the
bachelorette but it is unclear if a new
crop of contestants was brought in
you know what i'm taking things you know
day by day production on season 16 was
delayed by the coronavirus pandemic
right now it's still up in the air as
far as timing goes um
again the state of california just took
a big step back who knows what's going
on
so maybe we leave maybe we have to go to
a state that has their stuff together
and we can shoot
who knows maybe we're doing this in
texas i don't know but filming is now
underway
in palm springs we first met tasha on
colton underwood season
we didn't have like the physical
intimacy that i wanted
i definitely was falling in love with
colton um after the fantasy suite i did
tell him i love him
um i was getting to the point of being
in love with him
um that's a big word and that's
i don't know i just feel like we were on
our way there
and she ended up with john paul jones
after last year's
bachelor in paradise you had talked on
the show about seeing this woman as
potentially the mother of your children
one day i mean do you still
feel like you could be on that road one
day when she was ready if that happened
i think it's definitely possible for
sure but they broke up in october of
last year
leaving tasha free to be the
bachelorette i
the one i'm really hopeful for the
future and i'm really looking forward to
the person i do find
et spoke with bachelor alum ali
fedotowsky
right as the news broke clarentia and i
have to get your opinion
as an iconic bachelorette on all this
what do you think
is happening i
i think from what i've read what i'm
what i've heard is that claire found the
one for her and left and i think that's
awesome like i think that's amazing
because to go back to what you just said
about why i was angry i think
like on my season a lot i mean again i
look back and i'm nothing but grateful
but at the time
um i knew my top two than the first
night i knew frank and roberto were like
i mean frank technically left me top
three but i knew my top two the very
first night oh gosh my nails my daughter
painted my nails
they're like all different colors i just
noticed but i knew they were my
um chapter the first night and i would
have probably sent everybody home but
then night one
and i went through it and you know
i feel like claire maybe she was like
there is no top two there's a top one
and i know it right now and i'm done and
i think that is so awesome not only that
she
figured that out if that's the case but
i think it's awesome of the show
to let that happen because i think
in my season if i hadn't said that they
that that wouldn't have been allowed
to like stop everything down or like
send a bunch of people home
um so the fact that they're like shaking
it up and like saying sure
fine you can go and we're gonna bring in
someone new i just think that's so much
fun i hope that's the case
you